[Musique]
mars 2020 isabelle contracte le coc vide
jamais elle n'aurait pu croire que la
malade il aurait touché autant
alors pour immortaliser la mort qui la
guette avant d'entrer dans l'ambulance
comme un réflexe cette photographe
professionnel à trappes sans l'appareil
ces images elle a bien cru que ce serait
ces dernières depuis le creux vide ne
l'a pas lâché elle l'a contracté
plusieurs fois au moment où elle nous
reçoit elle est à nouveau atteinte par
le variant delta depuis un an et demi
cette mère de famille de 48 ans ne
compte plus ses séjours à l'hôpital
elle fait partie des quelques milliers
de personnes atteintes d'un kobe de long
la maladie a mis un coup d'arrêt à sa
carrière professionnelle et à sa vie
sociale d'isabelle qu'on avait vous
contractez le commis de la première fois
alors aux alentours des 16 mars 2020
donc au moment où la france se confiner
exactement non j'ai commencé en fait à
tous et le lundi 15 j'étais en pologne
je faisais un reportage photo en fait
sur la forêt de biens volés de ça en
pologne
j'ai réussi à avoir le dernier avion qui
rentrait en france j'ai commencé à avoir
des dés comme des boule dans la gorge et
la bouche sur la langue avec des pics en
dessus c'était la première sensation et
quand je suis rentré le soir même et le
lendemain déjà je toussais beaucoup
beaucoup plus et de suite de dieu c'est
pas du tout au départ chez ma mère est
hospitalisée j'ai appelé l'infirmière
voir comment elle rentrait chez elle et
j'ai posé la question à son infirmière
en disant mais c'est quoi les symptômes
du co lead et elle m'a demandé lui
décrire ce que j'avais et elle m'a dit
écoutez je crois que vous avez de qobuz
vous rentrez chez vous et vous vous
isolez une semaine
donc je suis rentré on a tout
désinfecter et je me suis isolé à l
étage
j'ai pris toutes mes affaires en fait
mon sac que j'avais pas déballé je suis
monté je ne me rendais pas compte en
fait de mon état mais je pouvais plus à
peine parler donc j'ai appelé le samu je
leur ai expliqué que c'est le médecin
qui m'avait demandé de les appeler le
médecin est arrivé et ils m'ont emmené
donc j'ai juste pris
mon polaroïd numérique mon téléphone est
un livre en disant il ya en partant dix
ans à tout le monde à tout à l'heure
j'ai fait tous mes débuts en fait dues
aux reportages journalistiques je me
suis dit c'est un fait unique si je peux
avoir quelques images
qu'on ne pourrait pas avoir autrement
pourquoi pas et donc j'ai photographié
en fait mon arrivée
jusqu'à ma sortie de l'hôpital les
infirmières ans yves qu'est ce que c'est
un col idiot un colis de lons et on a au
bout d'un mois quand la plateforme
qu'ovide homme vous dit c'est fini on
vous suit plus
bout d'un mois s'était déjà je pouvais
pas me lever du lit je pouvais soit
brosser les dents me doucher enfin je
pouvais rien faire et en larmes jeudi
mais je fais quoi je suis pas guéri et
elle me dit bah oui mais nous le suivi
s'arrête là donc elle me dit d'écrire
tous les jours ce que je ressens pour
aller mieux de manière à pouvoir revenir
en fait sur les jours un passé et voir
qu'il ya un mieux et de là je me rends
compte qu'il n'ya pas deux il n'y a pas
de mieux en fait
les symptômes c'est ça me brûle dans la
poitrine je tousse beaucoup j'ai des
migraines des vertiges geffroy
[Musique]
sur la première partie c'est
essentiellement ça en fait la perte de
goût et de l'odorat oublié mais c'est
lodra reviendra le goût sera toujours
différents même aujourd'hui la
perception de certains aliments n'ai pu
lui n'est plus le même et c'est surtout
des douleurs à la poitrine qui qui
persistent
et des symptômes plus tard en fait
qu'ils sont
je les avais déjà eu à l'hôpital puisque
l'hôpital j'avais eu un des co niveau du
visage des courbatures qui sont assez
douloureuse et plus tard en fait j'ai eu
des fourmillements toute assez
rapidement fait deux qui sont apparues
aujourd'hui ses fondements je les ai
toujours les douleurs musculaires je les
ai toujours les douleurs articulaires en
couleurs c'est souvent le soir en fait
ça arrive en fin de journée la nuit
et les fourmillements c'est en
permanence
dans le pied jusqu'aux genoux en
fonction des crises a peu varié en fait
tout le côté droit la main c'est pas un
quasi permanent
mais dans les casses de crise forte
c'est tout le côté droit est aujourd'hui
reste le visage la partie droite la main
le pied jusqu'au jusqu'au genou et les
douleurs ça peut être des brûlures
aux poignets donc j'ai oublié d'enlever
mes bracelets ou des choses comme ça je
supporte plus les bagues
et ça oui ça ça ne part pas les vertiges
ne partent pas la migraine ne part pas
la fatigue
je fais quasiment plus de photos
et j'ai aussi perdu au niveau de la vue
sur l'oeil droit en fait j'ai toujours
c'est toujours floues et j'ai une gêne
au niveau de l'ebe la vie d'avant mais
plus du tout celle que j'ai aujourd'hui
je pensais que oui j'aurais eu peur de
mourir est assez
[Musique]
non je me suis dit que
mourir c'est une fois que l'on meurt on
n'est plus là mais j'ai pris conscience
que
nous si on meurt on meurt c'est surtout
les les proches qu'il faut préparer
nous une fois qu'on est plus là on sera
plus là de toute façon donc oui j'y
pense et plus à mes proches à mes
enfants
clairement elle isabelle a contracté le
vide alors qu aucun vaccin n'existe et
encore
oui
assez tard parce que comme j'avais
beaucoup de symptômes du côté de l'eau
les médecins en fait tout le monde
disait d'attendre
alors je dirais en fait que je ne suis
pas contre la vaccination parce que je
pense que toutes les personnes qui sont
à risque
ou âgées doivent se faire vacciner
avec maintenant l'expérience de ceux qui
sont autour de moi qu'ils ont eu
tous
ils n'ont pas eu très très fort et
non ceux qui n'ont pas été vaccinés par
exemple les cons qu'ils ont une première
fois avec la première vague ou même
aujourd'hui qui sont à vacciner ils
n'ont pas eu très très fort et je me dis
que peut-être
laissé en fait les gens qui sont sûrs de
l'avoir pas très fort avoir une des
anticorps
par un m et après en fait se faire
vacciner le coc vie de l'eau c'est un
mystère
mais dans cette maladie
des zones d'ombré il y en a bien
d'autres comme cette dernière vague
orthez par le variant au micron et qui
se répand de façon fulgurante alors que
90% de la population est vaccinée avec
l'apparition de micron et la persistance
d'une variante delta l'hôpital et les
services de santé sont débordés
si la proportion des non vaccinés reste
très importante par rapport à leur
nombre dans la population environ 10% au
près de la moitié des passions
réanimation le nombre des patients
vaccinés a augmenté certains ont fait le
choix de refuser la vaccination et de
fêtes de s'exclure socialement c'est le
cas de sébastien membres du mouvement
anti passe reims
asie merci beaucoup vous me disiez donc
dans la voiture que vous n'étiez pas
vaccinés pourquoi est ce que vous avez
fait ce choix aujourd'hui j'ai compris
en tant que citoyen éclairé que je
n'étais pas exposé aux formes graves
aujourd'hui moi je souscris tout à fait
et bien à la volonté pour certains
d'aller se faire vacciner d'ailleurs je
veux bien utilisé ce terme de façon à
rester cohérent par rapport à la
caricature qui parfois est fait sur vax
honte ivax c'est pas le sujet en fait
voilà mais cette nuance est nécessaire
et c'est important de le rappeler en
france yann donc le ps sanitaire bientôt
le pen vaccinale qui va être requis pour
accéder à certains
certains établissements pour certains
loisirs comment aujourd'hui est ce que
vous vous organisez votre quotidien je
suis donc comme des millions de
personnes dans une situation de
privation en fait il ya des pans entiers
de ma vie de citoyen qui n'existe plus
je me ré organiser autrement j'essaye
d'orienter mes centres d'intérêt sur des
choses qui sont beaucoup plus on va dire
vrai je j'utilise ce mot qui paraît
peut-être un petit peu étonnant c'est à
dire qu'en fait j'ai retiré tout le
superflu et je me recentre sur
l'essentiel et l'essentiel c'est
l'humain en fait donc je ne suis pas
seule en france à avoir ce statut de
citoyens de seconde zone et donc
finalement nous nous retrouvons entre
citoyens de seconde zone je ne me suis
jamais autant senti vivent depuis qu'on
m'a privé de certaines de mes libertés
mais est ce vraiment la faute de ces non
vaccinés si l'hôpital est saturé ou
est-ce à cause d'une question de moyens
nous avons posé ces questions au
professeur xavier monnaie chef adjoint
du service médecine et réanimation à
l'hôpital bicêtre on a une situation qui
est rendue difficile par deux choses
d'abord le fait que comme vous le savez
il ya beaucoup d'infirmiers qui sont
partis de l'hôpital public et notamment
dans les services de réanimation et puis
en plus les infirmer aujourd'hui comme
le reste de la population ils sont
victimes du colis donc il ya beaucoup
d'absentéisme skis démunis complètement
nos services de réanimation aujourd'hui
dans le service de réanimation dans
lequel je travaille sur 25 lits il y en
a dix qui sont fermées parce qu'on
manque d'infirmiers et donc pour
accueillir ces malades qu'ovide on est
en très grande difficulté c'est vrai est
ce qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes en vous
continuer à accueillir des malades
collines ou non continuer à accueillir
des malades kobe d'autant qu'on peut
le problème aussi c'est qu'il faut
accueillir les malades à côté les
malades qui ont pas le coc vite et
notamment l'épidémie de grippe qui est
en train de beaucoup augmenté et donc
c'est une bataille de chaque instant
pour essayer d'admettre ses patients
dans nos services de pousser les murs
pour pouvoir les mettre dans nos
services voire de les transférer dans de
service ce qui n'arrive jamais par
exemple
ici elle dit s'être on obligé de
transférer ces malades parce qu'il ya
plus de place pour les accueillir donc
on a vraiment vraiment une grande
inquiétude sur l'accueil de ces malades
en même temps il ya des nouvelles qui
sont quand même positive on sait
aujourd'hui avec certitude que ce
variant au micron il conduit - les gens
en réanimation que le variant delta des
données qui avait été publié par
l'assistance publique hôpitaux de paris
lundi montrent que quand on est à
l'hôpital on a trois fois moins de
chances de passer en réanimation quand
on a le au micron que le delta et ça
même s'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
arrivent à l'hôpital s'attend à protéger
le service de réanimation donc ça c'est
quand même une bonne nouvelle mais de
quoi sera fait l'avenir aujourd'hui
c'est très incertain pourquoi après deux
ans de pandémie l'hôpital public
semble-t-il toujours aussi démunis mais
en fait cette crise qu'ovide a révélé
toutes les faiblesses de l'hôpital
public qui existe depuis bien avant la
crise de l'hôpital public elles datent
pas du cobp id la première vague de
covin à stimuler tout ce qui avait de
meilleur dans l'hôpital public
l'enthousiasmé des gens la façon qu'ils
avaient de se battre contre la maladie
et puis aujourd'hui on subit de plein
fouet toutes les difficultés de
l'hôpital public une fois encore date
pas d'hier on a commencé cette vague la
première vague au vide alors qu'on était
en grève pour se battre pour défendre
l'hôpital public et aujourd'hui c'est
publie ses ces difficultés persistent
elles sont encore plus criante les gens
qui se sont battus pendant les vagues
précédentes n'ont pas envie de rester à
l'hôpital public qui sont partis des
services de réanimation à l'assistance
publique aujourd'hui environ 20% des
patients qui sont des patients qui sont
qui sont vaccinées seulement 80% des
malades c'est des malades qui sont pas
vaccinés donc ça montre bien que c'est
ces patients-là qui viennent encombrer
l'hôpital et donc la question elle se
pose aujourd'hui non pas de pas soigner
ces malades qui est éthiquement
inacceptable pour tous les soignants
évidemment mais la question c'est celle
de rendre la vaccination obligatoire
pour empêcher ces gens de venir
encombrer l'hôpital public près qu'est
ce que vous pensez des propos du
président de la république vis-à-vis des
non vaccinés qui font les emmerder qu'il
faut les pousser dans leurs
retranchements
quand tout et il faut tout faire pour
que ces gens se vaccine et jusqu'à
maintenant le président de la république
le gouvernement ont choisi une méthode
très incitative et ses propres l'a sans
doute un coup politique mais incite ces
gens à à se faire vacciner il faut tout
faire pour le faire après sur les moyens
en tant que citoyen ce propos moi me
choque un peu enfin dans leurs dents
dans l'eure dans leur forme mais sur le
fond complètement d'accord il faut tout
faire aujourd'hui pour vacciner les gens
et surtout ceux qui sont convaincus
qu'il faut pas se faire vacciner il ya
une partie des gens qui sont pas
vaccinés qui aujourd'hui sans doute
n'ont pas accès aux vaccins il ya des
personnes âgées qui sans doute ont pas
accès au vaccin mais il faut aujourd'hui
se bat pour que tous ceux qui sont
convaincus que le vaccin tel vaccin
de tout ce qu'on entend sur les réseaux
sociaux et tout ce qu'ils sont des faux
argument il faut obliger ces gens à se
faire vacciner je crois qu'on va y venir
de toute façon une vaccination
obligatoire donc je pense que la
vaccination obligatoire on devrait y
venir sauf si ces gens finalement sont
convaincus mais je crains que ça
n'arrive pas au niveau du personnel
soignant les contraintes kyôko vite sont
de plus en plus difficile à vivre deux
ans après le début de la pandémie les
nerfs sont à bout les organismes
souffrent considéré dans les premiers
mois de l' épidémie comme des héroïnes
les infirmières ont cette fois
l'impression d'être les laissés pour
compte du système hospitalier
infirmière à l'hôpital saint-antoine à
issia ne cache plus son désarroi face au
manque de moyens on a une montée en
puissance on n'est pas encore
complètement saturé au jour
d'aujourd'hui on a 22 patients si on
reçoit critique 80 patients hospitalisés
pour que vides dans les autres services
donc c'est vrai qu'on commence à monter
en puissance mais on est encore pas
saturé comme on l'a été sur les
précédents le vague est ce qu'il ya des
vaccinés parmi les gens que vous recevez
à l'hôpital et que vous conservez qui
sont atteints de ducobu de tout à fait
on a des patients qu'ovide vacciné
malheureusement je rappelle que le
vaccin n'a ne préserve pas de la
contamination il préserve des formes
graves n'est pas de la contamination
donc oui alors la proportion est
raisonnée il ya plus de non vaccinés que
de vacciner ça on va le dire mais mais
pour autant on est quand même sujet à
être contaminée quand on est vacciné moi
je l'étais non alors cette situation où
on sent que ça commence un petit peu à
craquer de partout est ce que vous
l'imputer aux non vaccinés est ce que
c'est eux qui sont responsables de cette
situation selon vous j'ai été scandalisé
quand j'ai entendu notre président dire
que les non vaccinés les responsables de
la situation des hôpitaux non ceux qui
sont responsables de la de la situation
de désopilants hausse et les
gouvernements c'est ce qu'ils ont fermé
nos lits c'est ce qu'ils n'ont pas à
recruter suffisamment de personnel c'est
ce qu'ils ont diminué les budgets à
l'hôpital d'année en année c'est eux les
responsables c'est pas les non-vaccinés
c'est pas la population est vaccinée qui
est responsable et c'est aussi le but ce
qui est responsable de la situation dans
laquelle on est pour certains comme
isabelle le coc vide c'est pour la vie
pour d'autres comme xavier ou aïcha la
maladie est devenue leur vie jusqu'à
quand